in other war related news my battle-ax
of a cousin Hilary Clinton is despicably
mouthing off on foreign soil
the former future president slammed
president Trump's North Korea policy as
quote dangerous and short-sighted today
during a speech in South Korea she
alleged quote picking fights with Kim
jong-un just puts a smile on his face
I think the real quote went like what
happened but we were translating it
obviously for for the American audience
the irony defies reason but then the
Clintons are immune to shame Donald
Trump is clemens von Metternich compared
to Hillary Clinton let's just establish
that first she has no credibility here
her disastrous handling of foreign
affairs from the failed Russia reset to
her awful handling of crises in Egypt
and Libya and elsewhere in the world it
should disqualify her from saying boo
about geopolitics but more than that she
and particularly her husband bear the
lion's share of the blame for the North
Korean nuclear crisis that we find
ourselves in in 1994 people might not
remember this
Bill Clinton refused to respond when Kim
Jong Il pursued nuclear weapons and when
Kim Jong Il refused to allow weapons
inspectors to review two of his nuclear
waste sites in complete violation of the
nuclear non-proliferation treaty then
Hillary Clinton was not just first lady
she was also later Secretary of State
she executed a North Korea strategy
known as this is not a joke strategic
patience strategic patience you you
couldn't make that up in political
satire and that strategic patience was
very unstraight because it only allowed
the threat to grow president Trump and
Secretary of State Tillerson their
handling of North Korea has apparently
been pretty good so far from from what
we can tell it's very hard we're getting
mixed signals we don't really were not
bad and we're not daily haven't been
obliterated yet you know he Trump's
secured the release of that american
student otto warmbier who was jailed by
the Kim regime during the Obama
administration but fine hillary is
bitter that she lost the presidency
twice she can't get over it she's
clearly being ripped apart from the
inside out
who cares the real offense here is that
she's criticizing US policy
and foreign soil there has long been a
taboo against doing this you know we
have robust political debates at home
and then abroad American citizens are
supposed to present a united front
they're supposed to refrain from
criticizing the present policy overseas
Hillary however is immune from shame
patriotism be damned my cousin what a
what a traumatic family reunion this
will be next year